[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome
I'm James Malone I'm a product manager
with Google cloud and I'm joined today
hi good afternoon Lou I'm a suite with
Google and I've been working on composer
since the inception and today we're
going to cover Google Cloud composer
first before I begin cloud composer
recently went GA and there was a lot of
work from Googlers to make it happen so
to all of the Googlers thank you but far
and above beyond that composer is a work
of love of the open-source community and
we wanted to take a second before we
begin today to say thank you to everyone
who has participated in the development
of Apache airflow who has given input
who's written code who has used it
truly thank you and we're excited to be
a part of the airflow community now with
composer the first thing that we want to
do today is give an overview of composer
so composer is a new service it's built
on a patchy airflow and we'll also talk
about air flow so you want to just level
set and talk about composer why we did
it what it does after that we're going
to go in-depth and talk about Apache
airflow we're gonna look at a dag we're
going to run through a demo of cloud
composer and then next ups on how you
can get involved with both airflow and
also cloud composer
so before composer there were a few ways
to create and schedule and manage
workflows on Google cloud platform and
to be totally honest they were not the
best at all so on one end you had very
low cost very easy but pretty inflexible
not so powerful solutions mainly just
putting something in a crontab
scheduling it and letting it run on the
more complicated end you had customers
that were developed developing really
complicated frameworks to schedule
orchestrate and manage things on Google
cloud platform really powerful but also
took a team of engineers to do in our
opinion that none of this is an ideal
solution because people are focusing on
things that are not really what they're
trying to do they're developing
orchestration engines they're developing
description languages they're not
focusing on what they set out to do
which was just having a workflow run and
monitoring that workflow from time to
time so we thought it should be easy to
create manage schedule and monitor
workflows across Google cloud platform I
call out all of those steps individually
because they're all really important
parts when you think about the lifecycle
of a workflow it's not about just
scheduling something and letting it run
it's not about just monitoring something
you mean we've really wanted to think
about the whole process holistically
together and find something that would
allow somebody to create this workflow
to schedule it to run to look at how
it's running and then manage that
workflow based on what's happening so we
came up with cloud composer cloud
composer if you didn't catch last week
because we didn't really make a lot of
noise because next was this week cloud
composer just recently went GA so it's
generally available in a couple of
regions inside of cloud platform and
it's based on Apache airflow so the best
summary of cloud composer is it's
managed Apache airflow so there's a few
things that we really wanted to tackle
with composer first we wanted an
end-to-end GCP wide solution to
orchestration and workflows second it
was really important to us that composer
works both inside of cloud platform and
outside to be totally blunt if we
develop something that just worked
inside of Google Cloud it really would
be missing the mark because hybrid cloud
multi cloud and just not locking people
in or all the fact of life so if we
develop something that was proprietary
we thought from the outset we would be
failing we wanted it to be really easy
we don't want a really complicated
workflow system because then people are
just wrangling with the infrastructure
the description language and that just
sucks it's not a great use of time it
was also really important to us that
it's open source for a few reasons again
we don't want you to be locked in we
want people to be able to look under the
hood see what's happening we also wanted
people to be able to contribute and and
be part of a larger community
a common question we've gotten since we
launched airflow into alpha and then
beta and GA is what's the difference
between composure is to manage to patchy
airflow service and just running air
flow on my own on the VM or set of VMs
so there's a few things that we try to
tackle first we wanted a seamless and
integrated experience with cloud
platform that means that composer is
available inside of our command line
tooling there's a Google API it's not
just a standalone thing that feels like
a separate product second we wanted
security with cloud composer you have I
am you have audit logging it's not just
a separate product it acts and feels
from a security and audibility
perspective the same as any other cloud
product we also wanted it to be easy to
use when things weren't going quite the
way you expect so when you're developing
with workflows or running workflows you
know some pieces of that workflow may
not always run exactly the way that you
want so stock driver integration was
very important to us and it's a
first-class citizen with composer we
also wanted to make it really easy to
manage your air flow deployment so that
doesn't just mean creating and deleting
your air flow deployment it means doing
things like setting environment
variables or installing and maintaining
Python packages things that you could
conceivably do on your own but aren't a
value-add when you're doing it on your
own because we've built on Apache air
flow there's a core set of support for
several products inside of Google cloud
platform so for example there's data
flow operators there's big query
operators there's cloud storage
operators and the support for Google
cloud platform products is expanding
with each airflow release and that's a
core part of what the air flow team is
doing either inside of the air flow team
themselves or with other teams inside of
Google is expanding the breadth and
depth of support for cloud platform
products inside of airflow really
importantly airflow supports a whole
host of things outside of GCP so it
supports services so you can go talk to
things like slab
sheera it supports technology so you can
go call rest api so you can go hit FTPS
all of the support for non Google things
is absolutely usable within airflow and
also cloud composer and we didn't want
to break or limit what you could do
outside of GCP with composer so all of
the cool things that you can do with
airflow outside of GCP are very usable
since our GA happened late last week not
a lot of people may have noticed so we
wanted to call out a few things that
just launched last week with our GA we
launched support for a couple of new
regions inside of GCP there's expanded
stack driver logging which you'll see
today and the demo there's expanded
cloud I am rolls and we took a bunch of
fixes that will appear in future
versions of airflow or new additions and
we back ported them to the cloud
composer release we try not really to
modify the cloud composer airflow
version too much from the mainline
version of airflow itself but once in a
while there are fixes tweaks additions
that we back pour our general philosophy
is unless there's a JIRA associated with
it we won't inject it into composer
because again we don't want to make a
composer a black box it's it's just not
a value add and it's an alternative form
of login since not a lot of people may
be familiar with airflow or may have
just heard of airflow we wanted to
quickly cover air flow some of the core
concepts just to establish a baseline
we're really excited about air flow we
love air flow and we want other people
to love airflow and get excited about
air flow if you are totally unfamiliar
with air flow it's an open source
project
it's incubating the Apache Software
Foundation it's been around for a few
years I think it's fair to say it's
become one of if not one of the leading
open-source package to create and
schedule workflows air flow is really
interesting because all of your
workflows our code they're Python codes
so they're highly approachable you can
do
a lot of different things and you'll see
part of that in the demo today you can
do things like programmatically generate
workflows which is really cool one of
the questions we faced especially
initially when we made a bet on airflow
about a year ago was why air flow what
we really wanted to do with composure is
tie the strengths of air flow is an open
source package and open source community
with the strengths of Google cloud
platform so Google cloud platform we
were very good at running infrastructure
creating services adding layers of
security auditability
maintaining cost but as I mentioned we
didn't have a workflow an orchestration
solution air flow did have a really
strong workflow orchestration solution
it had a whole bunch of connectors for
services inside of an outside of Google
cloud platform
it already had a description language
defined set of api's she wanted to join
the two as a union inside of cloud
Composer as we've developed in cloud
composer we've also started contributing
back to the airflow community the
kubernetes executor is a good example
and i'll talk about it a little bit
later in the deck of something that is
really interesting to us and something
that were very interested in there's a
few key concepts in airflow you may want
to be aware of if you've never used air
flow in-depth before first all your
workflows are graphs so workflows are a
series of tasks and those tasks can fit
into a graph and that can be a very
simple graph it can be just one node
which is bash script that just says two
all the time it can be a really
complicated graph which will show you an
example of our build system for air flow
which is a good example of a complicated
graph that graph has a series of tasks
tasks are essentially steps something
that happens maybe running a sequel
query running a bigquery query airflow
in those tasks has operators and sensors
an operator is essentially something
that tells something to do something so
a good example would be a big query
query operator tells bigquery to go run
a query there's also the concept of a
sensor and air flow which is essentially
a binary wait until something happens
when it's true it proceeds
airflow itself also has a lot of really
interesting deep functionality that we
evangelize people use inside of composer
is also another reason why we thought
the airflow is a great bet you can do
things like define connections and have
your workflows use certain connections
you can set s LA's on your workflows and
see what's meeting SLA and not you can
do things like pass information between
tasks there's a lot of really
interesting advanced functionality
inside of airflow generally we get a lot
of questions of can air flow do X Y or Z
often the answer is yes air flow
actually can do x y and z and with that
i'm going to turn it over for a look at
air flow in-depth thank you James
so with that being said you know we do
want to next what you knew so if I
reviewed some of the product details the
way how we construct a product and some
of the design decisions so we have made
so you know the capability is where
compose is so in car composer we
introduced this new concept called
environment really is very similar to
you know a kubernetes cluster what they
depart cluster is essentially it means a
collection of managers GCP resources
that gives you the functionality Nydia
to run Apache airflow inside a single
choose to be project you could create
multiple
composing environments and all the
environments are integrated with Google
Cloud storage I am stuck travelogues as
well as call I am so the way to interact
with the product the following you can
use Cloud SDK you can use compendium you
can use our REST API functionality-wise
all three masters are equivalent however
I do want to point out one difference in
color SDK to make it a convenient for
the composer users and so that you don't
have to manage to set of command-line
tools you know there's composer comma
line tools but at the same time there's
also like elf LACMA line tools so what
we did in a product
we took a tunnel to or outflow command
commands to loop through the composer
g-cloud command so that in a single
place you can manage both your composing
environment at the same time you can
interact with the composer with the Elfa
environment only I mentioned that a
composing environment is really a
collection of GCP resources so here I'm
going to give you so if I could zoom one
live being and then explain how and why
we decided use the following industry
resources to construct the composer
service a very high level you notice
there are two projects one is got a
customer project the other one's got a
tenant project so custom apology I
probably the ones you film in a wealth
you know in track was used to be by
creating a GP project that's that's the
customer project and tenant project is
probably a concept new it's nothing it's
really is the same as an ordinary GP
project it's just the case that this
tiny project is managed and owned by
Google as we walk through the detailed
architecture we explain why we decide to
make this design decision that a portion
every resource actually lives inside the
tenant project
I'll throw yourself you know if you look
at the the way how it's being
constructed it has a number of sort of a
micro service like flavor you have an L
flow web server you have a well flow app
scheduler al flow metadata database
those components just naturally match in
a map to the serve the the the wide
range of GCP services we offer so for
example I start with outflow scheduler
and L flow worker if you look inside a
coupon any class that we decide to host
both the worker and a scheduler inside
Kubrick cluster the reason we do that is
that so you allows you to conveniently
packaged your workflow application
dependencies because essentially all
your all your tasks can run inside the
containers the worker and the scheduler
and they communicate alright is through
the sealer executors
and then movie next we have this clásico
proxy and then we decide to host the elf
flow metadata database inside a tenant
project so that only the service account
you use the creator composing
environment has access to the metadata
database it's really for enhancing
security as we believe that a cloud
sequel or the elf of database shows all
the valuable metadata information
regarding workflow think about you have
like connection credentials store in a
database you obviously don't want anyone
in your project be able to access that
credential information walk down on the
right side you know we have the airflow
web server interacts with the database
surface all workflow information and now
it's we decide to host the web server
inside ji-ae
so that is puppies sort of accessible
you don't need to have the clumsy proxy
set up be able to access the web server
but we do realize at the same time you
don't want to make your web server open
to anyone on internet so as a result we
collaborate with another service in
Google in Google Cloud it's called
identity a while proxy so that you know
only authorized users would be able to
access the web server later on in the
time of session we'll be able to give
you a way to have a sense and a feel how
that works and we also make it extremely
easy for you to config access the web
server you know is exactly the same way
as how you would configure I am policy
moving left we have G says we use Jesus
as a convenience store for you to state
your tax deploying a new workflow to
composer is as simple as drop your fire
into the Jesus pocket we understand that
there are needs sometimes you need to
stage your workflow artifacts and we
also make use we make some we make it a
manager service for you so that your
artifacts is nicely staged in the Jesus
packet which later allows you to sort of
get retrieve those artifacts back out
finally everything's being you know all
the interactions were logs
of being streamed a to structure of
I hope Fleur has a very the UI itself
comes together with Pascal ox but you
can't really find out what's happening
if for example there's a hell floor
Walker crash well there's an outflow
exception in yourself the workflow was
scheduled runs into exception at that
point you sort of lose that I lose the
visibility and what's happening that's
why we decided that we it makes a lot of
sense to offer this additional
stackdriver login community with the
architecture and now I'm going to
explain a little bit about workflows
because not I not everyone is sort like
a familiar with workflow and not the way
how our flow experts workflows so at a
very high level a workflow consists of a
collection of tasks and then it was and
the there interdependency relationships
so in this very in this case you have
for example you have some flower in HDFS
and then you know whenever you have new
for addition to HDFS your workflow you
may want to kick off your workflow such
that it will copy the file from HDFS G
says once it's in G says or Google Cloud
Storage you maybe you want to trigger a
bigquery operator that does something
loaded data in and a subsequently maybe
run some query and make the result of
vailable maybe while a snag notification
so a few things you probably have
noticed in the in this example workflow
description there are tasks associate
with workflows for example you want to
run a bigquery job there was a
dependencies you want to wait until the
data is available in G says and then you
study OB a query job there's also a
component of trigonis something you know
I have a file that Assad now appears in
my um primer or HDFS then that starts my
workflow so those are some of the
elements or building blocks in our flow
workflows I'm going to start with
actually give everyone an example how
you can build sort of a very simple
workflow that
consists of two or three tasks so really
two outflow
unlike other sort of orchestration
workflow solutions they they express
workflow as code so instead of you know
having this giant configuration file of
spasming your workflows you write your
workflow as Python code roughly speaking
about five steps for you to define a
workflow in our flow the first thing is
like important you know import Alf you
know from the outflow system you
imported a dag which is a with the
acronym for a directed acyclic graph
which is really another way of saying
workflow and then you try to import all
the operators that you're going to use
in the workflow in this case a big query
operator and then you know there are
also like a trigger rules which allows
you to specify the inter task
relationship now once you have all
import statements ready in the next step
is for you to define all arguments to
your task or to your workflow you
probably notice that there's a t4 tag
args
this is really a very convenient thing
that's providing an outflow so that you
know if you do feel that you have common
arguments to a number of your tasks
instead of specifying those argument at
each and every single outflow task you
can specify them at the beginning of
your workflow and it just pass that in
automatically by the elf low-tech model
imagine if you are going to use a
configuration that's probably hard
because you probably have to copy and
paste a lot of duplicated lines of code
once you have all the workflow data has
specified now you can you're going to
introduce define your workflow dag equal
to die you give a name you give a
schedule interval are you passing the
default acts as a nation now within a
dag you start to define your tasks in
this case we have two tasks you know I
have bigquery operator tasks you also
have a big query to Jesus operator as
James mentioned earlier our flow has
wide range of supported TCP operators
both be clear operator as well as the
big word cloud storage operator they are
available in elf law once you space for
all the tasks defined all the task
arguments the next step is actually for
you to chain them up by giving some
dependency in this space for example the
the line simply says hey I want to run
big queue elf local media query first
after that I run the export to GCS task
as simple as that
now the reason why we decided to go with
this routine I'll flow in composer is
really there are a lot of nice things
that you can do once tag workflow can be
specified as programs it gives you
vision control it allows you to
dynamically generate the tags it also
give you the choice of you know support
templates so that you know you have a
skeleton via workflow and then be able
to then I mean dynamically instantiate
your workflows like I said the first
thing you know with tag with the in our
flow tags in the language choice the
supports like ginger templating so you
can spice for a template come in and
every single run you will be able to
reconfigure that task
likewise think about you need to
generate a thousand tasks or like a
10,000 tasks of the same type it's
probably fairly tedious to be able to do
that in a configuration language so with
tag as code it's just like a simple two
line of code would give you like a
thousand tasks the third thing is like
I'll flow so you know you sort of a
naturally match the the the programming
or the software model or software
development process where you have
modules and sub-modules so here in L
flow you have workflows and the sub
workflows they're called tags and sub
bags
so in the example on left side you could
have many tasks or if you want to
realize that you want to create a
reusable tags what you can do is just
package those tasks
into a sub bag and they include a sub
bag in the non attack so with all that
I'm going to give a composer demo so in
that demo we're going to show you how to
use the how to how to interact with the
product and also for example we just
cover how does that look like how do you
query workflow status
how would you trigger workflow execution
for my external system all right now
we're going to switch to the demo
we'll turn on screen mirroring and then
switch to the demo here
this is also known as the game of how
quickly do we know Chrome OS all right
screen mirroring is on so hopefully we
can switch the demo now
now we go
Chrome to the rescue that's you can't
over tell I'm not a chrome user all
right well let's so early as I mention
that
sorry about that cool so we have us go
back we have a very simple and an each
console interface for you to interact
with the environments so to create a
composing environment that's what you
need to do specify a name Google next
specify number of notes you want like
you know three knows well ten knows how
many number knows if you want which
location you want to deploy nice Asian
RCS one you have the option to define
machine type if you do feel like you're
going to have some CPU intensive
workflows you can try to configure your
composing environment with some more
powerful machines for you and likewise
you know you can also specify network
and subnet and this is for the case when
you need to have shared VPC where you
and i guess we use some network we have
defined in your project there's one
thing I want to call in in a
configuration is that we do allows you
to provide your own service account you
don't have to rely on the default
compute engine service account instead
you can supply any service account you
gave this from the man this allows you
to sort of restrict the possible set of
services that you composer interact in
environment and password interact with
we do allows you to have you know our
flow configuration overrides you know
for example you know if you want to
increase your diet low timeout value
from 100 seconds or 200 seconds this way
you can specify some of the air flow
configuration overrides
once you have all the parameters input
and just create a clip yeah that's we
need to do to bring our composing
environment now
while waiting for the environment we
created right now it takes a while
because as I mentioned we have we host
the alpha web server inside
and it just simply takes GAE like 10
plus minutes to get the application
deployed for you so we have pre created
a composer time oh environments and so
we can take a look those are the service
account those are the name you got a
view of all the details pertaining to
your environment only I mentioned that
we use GC has to to deploy workflows so
just click into the text folder we have
a one simple tag is the PQ demo which is
the example just work that everyone to
deploy a new dag is as simple just copy
a file into this Jesus back here
meanwhile if you want to interact with
the service service and then try to you
know interact with an outflow of you I
understand like what are the workflows
as simple you'd like it you don't need
to do run through like clumsy proxy
setup simple click gives you the air
flow web UI this is the simple that is
attack time Oh Doug I just mentioned you
know it's like really like two or three
tasks it's not to mention to everyone
it's not to say that you know you can
create a more complicated X James
mentioned earlier that you know we're
seeing Google we have this complicated
dag that really helps us to run CS city
so so that will make sure that all
changes are submitted to our flow
upstream will not break GCP operators
the other part I want to show to
everyone is earlier I mentioned that
this the web server is protected by I ap
and only authorized user could access
the web server so I'm going to open an
ignition window
all right just give me one second
James I needs your magical power to
restore my demo page no worries
cool thank you
we also have somebody who knows the
Chrome keyboard commands well and you'll
need to copy and paste the help you
should be said
so what I'm trying to do is I try to log
in with just my sort like a person at
gmail and he used this two-factor
authentication I'm sorry I forgot about
my foot but you trust me it works
I noticed I like a few a few are taking
in photos of the snail please try it
offline and for the coffee that you are
I'm guarantee that you wouldn't be able
to access this this server this website
cool so the other thing I mentioned
early that because we have this IEP
proton you're a gives you the guarantee
that only authorized user could access
to your tax it gives the opens up a lot
of possibilities so here we're gonna
have a demo where you know you actually
try to invoke a trigger attack execution
for my GCF you know you're writing your
own function really doesn't really
matter what is GCF or you know our
different computer as long as you know
you are you have the necessary
I am credentials you are being added to
the I am policy of composer you would be
able to remotely trigger the execution
of a dag so I'm going to test this
function what it does is behind the same
is this function we're trying to call
the URL as L float was a host is web
server in the same application as the L
flow excuse me our flow water hoses API
server in the same application as a web
server so behind the saying this really
does is send a restful request to the
web server I just showed you as to a
page refresh now you see a task being
triggered and this is the menu idea
generated by outflow so this is what I
mean that you know once you have the dag
you could trigger the dagger anywhere it
gives you a lot of like
spin it here so that you don't
necessarily need to have access to
g-cloud not necessarily need to have
access to proxy or even Google Cloud
console the that's just weird about this
you know while we're waiting for this
you know I just realize the it this
particular tax accuses where they
completed menu at this time so the other
thing I want to show to everyone is in
this GA release we also support Cooper I
depart operator so in the past it has
been paying for you to manage
dependencies as James mentioned in our
lives you know we do make it a
convenience so that you can use store
any Python packages that sometimes if
your dependencies live outside of Python
then what working doing right that's why
in this one we realize that we make it
very convenient we back part of the
kubernetes heart operator in our flow
1.10 which was just released a couple
weeks back but it was who will make you
just walk out a box for you so you don't
have to worry about it you know what's
the service kinda was the credential all
that stuff so as a result of that I'm
going to show you another demo which we
really just
yeah
that's just waiter one more two minutes
for the doctor show up this is what I
mentioned that out flow has this
directory scan interval which allows you
to specify how often you want to scan
for new changes new files or new
workflows in your tag folder again
there's some default value but you know
to a composer we give you the option to
override that default configuration
value while waiting for the workflow
demo to show up I plan you know we can
look a bit more into details about what
this outflow UI offers to you you have
different views of your dad it is a
graph view a tree view
you also can you can also see the code
at any time it just in just in case you
need to like a sort of a switch back and
forth between the graph representation
we workflow and the code representation
you could also conveniently you know add
connections to your workflows only
imagine that our flow does span the
store or the connection credentials in
the metadata database and it also
convenient offer you this outflow this
web UI for you to mutate your
connections anytime you can also see all
your configuration that comes together
with this particular installation as I
mention like those configuration can be
later on changed through the manager
service yeah and that's come back now we
do notice that as we added this code a
depart example not intend to pretty
straightforward we'd run let's take a
look at a code so as I mention you have
all the just recap you have all the
import statements at the top then you
have all your definition where you work
flow data
now you're gonna read for in your
workflow now you define your tag after
that you define your task so in this
case we have two tasks the tasks the
first one is really like a bachelor that
print date the second one is what I
mentioned you have a culinary part
operator which allows you to in this
kids get a per image and a computer the
value of pi' at any time you could sort
of this is the outflow WI while you can
inspect the log output sometimes there
might be a delay in how soon
those locks appears this is where that
the stackdriver logging is helpful so
let's try to look at the logs that
spewed at the same time by the worker
as you notice that we have this pot
launcher that's actually related to
launching a pod
so the nice thing we added into the
stack driver lock is that we organized
the stack driver lock and then provide
labels for you to access the task so I'm
going to here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to filled out all logs pertaining
to this specific task
there you go you see all the logs that
being generated for you well at the same
time you know you may take our flow for
a while before they have the logs appear
under logs populating for you and now
the task is done we can take a look at
the output as you notice that they you
know you start out to keep hard and then
I just waited for that you keep how to
be done out of some at some point let's
see how I try to squirrel over there we
go
there's a job pending job running and
then you prints the value of pi' and
then finally I got a task successful so
we started that concludes the demo
session feel free to try out a service
offline like like I said I promise that
you can't access my web server alright
quick recap on the demo
you know we showed you how to create a
composing environment the various ways
to interact with the environment how did
you monitor workflows how to deploy
workflows monitor would flows trigger
workflow from an external source and
then inspect your workflow status with
IO flow logging as well as thank Joe
Valachi
past you James excellent and just to add
on the security that we use for the
identity we're a proxy is the same Lord
lover load balancer level security
that's used for things like the Google
Cloud console so we are paranoid about
security so the two-factor
authentication is a good example of that
it's it's very core security so it you
would have seen a rejection and that
rejection is handled very low down in
the stack so I want to talk about next
steps in terms of our involvement with
air flow in terms of where composure is
going in terms of how you can get
started there's a lot of composure
questions that we get and we just want
to go ahead and answer some of the most
common questions please
you know if you have questions I'll have
details on how you can bug us please bug
us we are here as a
we are not shy of questions we love
input we're here to collaborate with
people these just happened to be the
questions that we get a 99% of the time
there's questions on can people install
their own Python packages air flow
operators Python specific themes the
answer is yes inside of the cloud
storage bucket that contains your DAGs
you can either add custom Python modules
that's the interesting thing about
everything being code there's also
specific folders to add plugins for air
flow itself there's questions on whether
we touch the environment after it's been
created the answer is no one of the soft
spots on air flow right now is how
changes are handled version diversion
right now we think it's best that we
don't change your environments version
or a versioning of the components once
you deploy it that may change over time
as the air flow community as composer
matures will clog composer be offered in
more regions yes we are actively working
on it
Chie is a good example of that is there
a graphical way to create DAGs a very
very common question the answer is no
but this is something of extreme
interest to us and also of interest to
the air flow community so the answer is
no but I would expect that it will
happen at some point in the future which
version of Python can be used with
composer this is probably the most
composer specific question that we get
right now it's 2/7 we are actively
working in on Python 35 support you
could probably expect that in a future
composer release future directions for
cloud compilers so we shut off some of
the work we've done with kubernetes the
intersection of kubernetes and air flow
is exceedingly interesting to us Google
in terms of the composer team and other
teams have been involved in work for
kubernetes and airflow the kubernetes
executor is a good example of that it's
not the last example or the the end of
the line I think in terms of air flow
and kubernetes we're also working on
additional operators so we want to
support additional API surface area
coverage of the products that are
already inside of air flow so things
like data proc or bigquery data flow
we also want to expand support for new
products inside of airflow that our GSP
products third resource usage so right
now you can create your composer
environment with fixed size you can also
resize that environment we're also
thinking of ways that we can increase
the elasticity of that environment based
on workflows that are executing on that
environment much like a lot of our
managed services we want to tightly
constrain the resources that you're
using for an environment to what's
actually going on in that environment
there's a ton of different things that
you can do to get involved with either
airflow if you don't like composer and
that's totally ok or composer itself
airflow the patchy website for airflow
is a really good place to get started
there's links to the mailing list they
have pretty active mailing lists there's
a lot of information for how to get
involved in that community in terms of
composer we have our documentation for
the product there's also a google group
mailing list that you can join you know
please ask questions on that mailing
list there's also a Stack Overflow tag
that we look at as a team so if you have
composer specific questions please use
that tag because the more questions that
you ask with that tag the less likely it
is that other people will need to hunt
and peck for that information over time
and we just can't anticipate all of the
questions that might come up over time
as a plug there is a meetup group if you
happen to be local to the Bay Area for
air flow it there is going to be an
event in September which is going to be
hosted by the cloud composer team at the
Google Sunnyvale office so if you are
local please sign up we just put up the
air flow of our the meetup event for
that so something to check out if you're
curious with that thank you all very
much for being here we sincerely
appreciate it and again thank you to
everyone who used composer and gave us
feedback we're open to questions we have
five minutes if you have questions
please come up to the mic happy to
answer any questions you guys have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]